hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen the holidays are fear
which means we've officially entered
into the eating and entertaining season
of the year and sure a little indulgence
is totally fair game but nobody wants to
be playing catch-up after a six-week pie
sausage roll and booze bender thankfully
we've partnered with all brands to
lighten up your family's favorite
holiday recipes with some sneaky
high-fiber swaps that will crush your
cravings and unchain you from those
brutal New Year's resolutions first up a
lightened up crab using appetizer my
sweet and tangy turkey meatballs i pulse
a half a pound of cremini mushrooms and
a food processor until they reach a
ground meat light consistency mushrooms
are a great local substitute for ground
meat so you can stretch your calories
and portions without compromising flavor
transfer them to a large bowl then do
the same with a cup of high-fiber all
brand regional cereal this is a great
high fiber low calorie swab for your
traditional white bread crumbs a perfect
way to get 40% on your daily fiber needs
add that to the bowl then mix in a pound
of extra lean ground turkey one egg a
clove of minced garlic 1/2 a teaspoon of
toasted sesame oil 1 teaspoon of reduced
sodium soy sauce 2 tablespoons of
chopped cilantro 2 tablespoons of green
onions and a quarter teaspoon each of
salt and pepper
roll into two dozen meatballs and bake
at 400 degrees for 15 to 28 minutes
meanwhile let's work on that sauce in a
saucepan honest together a quarter cup
each of poison sauce and rice wine
vinegar 1 cup of unsweetened apple sauce
1 tablespoon of reduced sodium soy sauce
2 tablespoons of apple butter and a
teaspoon of sesame oil simmer over low
heat until thick and hot then toss the
cooked meatballs with the warm sauce
serve them with some huge holiday themed
toothpicks and enjoy
when food is an abundance at the
holidays stocking up on fiber is key
fiber has so many important health
benefits you can keep you regular help
lower your cholesterol control your
blood sugar and even can help you
maintain a healthy weight men need
around 38 grams a day and women around
25 grams so some of these easy swaps are
a great way to meet your target now it's
time for my healthy holiday apple and
pumpkin crisps for the filling I mix
together two peeled diced apples one cup
of pumpkin puree three tablespoons of
dried cranberries a tablespoon of minced
candied ginger 2 teaspoons of
whole-grain flour one and a half
tablespoons of maple syrup 2 teaspoons
of melted butter quarter teaspoon of
cinnamon and a generous pinch of salt
working now on the crisp topping I
combined two tablespoons each of rolled
oats whole grain flour and brown sugar 3
tablespoons of chopped pecans quarter
teaspoon of cinnamon 2 teaspoons of
ground flax seed a quarter cup of melted
butter and 1/2 a cup of all brand buzz
trust me
you're not gonna be picking out
leftovers after you eat this so I
transfer the filling to two oven-safe
ramekins and finish it off with the
crumble topping bake at 375 degrees for
25 to 30 minutes and enjoy
see healthy eating at the holidays
doesn't have to mean giving up on all
your family's face just a few simple
high-fiber cereal swaps and you'll be on
your way to the new year resolution free
thanks so much for watching guys more
great healthy holiday ideas be sure to
subscribe to my channel and I'll see you
next time on hobbies kitchen